this story is about a man with a vision
to reinvent the world's financial system
by creating a truly decentralized
currency for the masses
that currency
was tara
and his name
was dog
so i said to his face
your size
is not size
right
i'm sorry the question was to state your
name and your date of birth but uh
moving on absolutely sorry to interrupt
but francis coppola said our
self-correction mechanisms won't work
when people start panicking dude i don't
have time to talk to the poor okay
especially not on twitter so tell her
i ain't got no time to debate her and i
got no change on me to give her
i i actually don't tweet that that's
kind of mean
so in the past month i've been covering
stable coins a lot and my question is
what makes ust different from other
stable coins
usd
is not just a stable coin it was
sure it's pegged at a dollar not for
long itself isn't what makes stablecoin
so vital to an ecosystem here we go
again a decentralized currency is the
key to building financial infrastructure
that is beyond the reach of regulations
and borders
and to achieve this we need mass
adoption and to get mass adoption we
need scalability
ust
is the only stable coin that is yield
bearing interchange and most importantly
scalable
unlike another stable point that i won't
name
it it's died you don't die from maker
dial yeah it's the most unscalable piece
of [ __ ] i've ever seen
but what if usd were to break the peg
then it would depend on luna to save ust
but the fact that it's de-pegged
investors will pull out a luna and tank
the price so it's literally a debt
spiral
investors pulling out luna is trading at
80 right now usd's market cap is at 30
billion making us the third biggest
stable coin
does that look like pulling out to you
because i know
what pulling out looks like
right yeah
and that's definitely not it
so if you're trying to spread foot with
a little article
then you're gonna have to try a little
harder than that i'm just trying to get
my question oh really
are you really or are you actually from
maker dow trying to write a hit piece on
tara
well
here's something you can write about
[Music]
ticker where are we at luna is at 83.4
usd is exactly at a dollar sir
beautiful g-men how much bitcoin do we
have in reserve uh we bought 1.5 billion
worth so far make it 10 billion we're
gonna be the largest holder of bitcoin
in the world
john cook
update
board pool's been deployed all cbx
missions will go to it
you hear that
we're going to starve three pull to
death
it's over for dying you're crazy why
don't you report back to your little
guys at maker doubt that i'm here to
stay
and not only that
but i'm here to destroy every other
stable coin in my way
and by my hand
die
will die
let's go
this is not sustainable and you know it
the economics of it makes no sense
you see my team
this is my head of research
look at him he has a crypto punk has his
profile so don't talk to me about
economics
anyone here dissatisfied with how much
they've made with tara
anyone here want to work on another
blockchain [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no
looks pretty sustainable to me
all you detractors don't you see what
you're missing out on
so either you shut the [ __ ] up and buy
some luna or keep tweeting and stay
[ __ ] bored
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
we're trading a bit below a dollar we're
at
0.998 now thanks sticker
well some people are worried about it
getting de-pegged again
tweet this for me
and on
you can listen to ct influencers about
usc the pegging for the 69th time or
for a run instead sort of interrupt um
would you peg that 0.98 now
it's all good
yeah yeah we're good
we're good right
finance is calling
do you want to pick up
no
all right let's sell some [ __ ]
bitcoins to pair market makers
sir with that size it might take the
whole crypto market i don't care if it
thanks to home market defend the pay for
[ __ ] sake sending out a 700 million
bitcoin loan to our market makers
if usd goes down
and bring the whole [ __ ] market with
me
no
what is it
it's trading below 90 cents now
dope
dope
it's at 87 cents now
are you there and just like that when
tara needed him the most
he vanished
this video is only made possible for its
sponsor one inch one inch is the biggest
dex aggregator so it scans all
decentralized exchanges to find the best
cryptocurrency prices i use it all the
time to swap my tokens because sometimes
it's complicated and requires multiple
dexes and one inch will find the most
optimal path for you so you won't pay
too much in fees if you trade a lot this
will help you improve your roi also
since it's decentralized you won't face
any risk of losing your funds through a
centralized entity by the way not only
are they the biggest decks aggregator
but they have recently surpassed major
decks uni-swap in direct dab swaps and
they also have a mobile app available on
ios and android so if i hear an
important news that can have an impact
on trading and i'm not a home i can now
use the one inch wallet to make that
trade thank god check them out use my
link here and try your mobile app all
right now back to the video
i
i i i
don't know what to do anymore you know
what to do
like everything in life you need to make
a sacrifice
no no no no okay i i need my ust i need
my stable coin
why do you think you're so attached to
your stable coin
well i'm i mean isn't that the whole
point when you were a child
did you have a good relationship with
your parents oh for [ __ ] sakes not
everything is about childhood traumas
okay
stability doyoung we need stability you
need to get a stable job do you think
you can get that with the b plus huh
how do you expect to get into stanford
if you're playing starcraft all day go
study for sats you'll thank me once you
get a stable job
debug
these stables look amazing
[Music]
go on
[Music]
embrace them
[Music]
uh
[Music]
did he cry
is he going to pump my bags
[Music]
tara is more than usd
we are strong not because of how stable
usd was not because of how high the
price of luna rose
we're strong because of our people
because we're lunatics
they can attack usd they can break our
peg but they cannot
kill our passion
we are a team
we've always been
and we will always be
nothing has changed
terra is still the most robust
blockchain with the best talent pool
right now
this ecosystem will not fail
as long as together
we fight for it
[Music]
so i've decided
to proceed and save this ecosystem no
to save our ecosystem
our invention
our baby
we will fork the current chain and start
anew
reborn
into luna 2.0
[Music]
the tara community is my family
i will always be here
no matter how hard it gets
[Music]
let's build it back up again
together
but this time there will be no stable
right
but this time there will be no stable
coin right
[Music]
[Music]
you